un casse tête logistique s'annonce sur
la côte de beaupré le 28 juillet jour de
la visite du pape françois la route 138
sera complètement fermée pendant douze
heures de 3 heures du matin à 15 heures
c'est sûr que en raison des entraves
nous on pense fermé commerce les
commerçants doivent déjà planifier en
conséquence nous mêmes on doit rentrer
dans mon commerce avancée par le matin
donc nous on a déjà deux mois ce qui
paie c'est super on va venir s occuper
de nos ennemis tout seul mais je crois
pas que la boutique sera ouverte
planifier vos déplacements soient
reportées ou encore devancé les camions
autobus et roulottes ne pourront pas
circuler sur une portion de 25 km entre
la côte de l'église avoir chatel et la
rue des montagnards à beaupré l'impact
pour les automobilistes et les cyclistes
sera moindre en direction est lente rêve
ne sera contre château richer et beaupré
des voies de contournement locales
seront mises en place mais ça se
complique pour les véhicules lourds ils
devront emprunter un important détour
vers le saguenay l'industrie du
camionnage s'attend à des impacts de
possibles retards en espérant qu'il n'y
aura pas de rupture de certains produits
en ce qu'on transporte les produits
pétroliers ou si les produits
alimentaires c'est de réorganiser
des livraisons de
précéder un important périmètre de
sécurité sera également érigé autour du
sanctuaire de sainte anne de beaupré les
agents de la sûreté du québec seront aux
aguets le pape françois ii parce qu'ils
représentent pourrait peut-être faire
face à des gens qui pourraient être
moins bien intentionnés ce qu'on ne
souhaite pas mais on se doit d'assurer
la sécurité à tous points de vue une
visite historique pour laquelle les
autorités invitent à la patience la
propriétaire de cette animalerie ne s'en
fait pas trop moi je vois autre
désagrément mais ce sont eux qu'il faut
réorienter pour ceux qui n'auront pas
chouette se déplacer l'état de la
circulation sera diffusé en temps réel
sur le site du ministère des transports
et celui de la ville ici qu'un mais
carpentier radio-canada sainte anne de
beaupré